week the country honors a crucial part
of the health care system the nurses who
help save lives daily the nurses
association saying there are more than 4
million registered nurses making them
the highest percentage of our country's
health care workers
and there are many different ways to
support our health care heroes in
recognition of national nurses week we
caught up with the niece of one nurse
who started a special campaign in her
honor to help other nurses kirsten joyce
shares their story she was a feisty rn
michelle dimirio's aunt nora worked as
an rn in both williams and phoenix
arizona for more than two decades i
remember one time i was with her and
there was an accident she pulled over on
the side of the road and helped she
didn't care that we had been in traffic
for two hours
she was just one of those women that
always landed a helping hand tragically
nora and her husband were both murdered
in their williams arizona home during a
burglary in 2017. michelle wanted to
create something very special in honor
of her aunt raising money through bags
from nora bags from nora are self-care
bags for health care workers a 25
donation bringing a smile to a health
care worker letting them know you
recognize the toll the pandemic has had
in their lives and the sacrifices
they've made michelle also created a
foundation called the be daring
foundation tackling mental health she's
also planning a virtual 5k later this
month and a special mental health summit
which she hopes can raise enough money
to help out other women pursuing a
career in nursing putting them towards
scholarships for nurses who want to go
back to school in honor of my aunts our
goal is to provide at least one full
ride
valued about 75 000 depending on how
much we raise along with a few community
college scholarships kiersten joyce live
local now